[Music]
you look beautiful tonight
thank you who are you talking to my
beautiful wife of course not my
beautiful best friend
David joy can you believe your dad is
turning 60 so oh you know what he needs
to do
start eating soft foods we won't have to
get dentures in a minute that's not our
teeth who work there huh okay we better
go work on our speeches for your father
y'all better bring your A game I've got
a little something special planned for
the night you don't have to say that to
Sam he kills it every year I guess I do
don't I see you guys these speeches make
me so nervous cuz you know dad's just
gonna pick it apart yeah thumbs and ours
let the audience know you're not
prepared you know what you're going to
say please that's been the last year
crafting two pages of hilarious jokes
it's about dads mustache damn that's
good
hey happy birthday Laurie mom hi Daddy
hi darling son
[Music]
shoot monster yes son one should never
stop evolving now if you'll excuse me I
have to welcome my guest look at you two
old-time and Kim can't you give me a
twirl
[Music]
[Laughter]